welcome back to computer file you've got
um another story for us
well today i thought we'd talk about the
great morris internet worm of
1988 which was a watershed moment in the
history of the internet
it was kind of a transitional event in
the internet history
because up until this point it had all
been a very uh sort of academic
network where we'd all got on very well
we'd all share
data with all shared programs we'd all
sort of helped each other
and then this event which was actually
well it was november the 2nd 1988 so
that's almost a
anniversary now at this point i think
there are around 60 000
computers on the internet or the arpanet
as it probably was it was sort of
transitioning at that point
and then this
thing happened and suddenly a lot of
computers found themselves under attack
and this was a worm program that was
moving around the internet
and infecting computers and it was
helped quite a lot by the fact that
everybody almost used the same computers
at the time everybody was
running on vax computers pretty much
apart from a few sun
computers which were also coming into
use
there were a few others but because
they're all using sort of the same
computer it was quite easy to attack
so uh this thing was
uh appeared and people suddenly found
them
all their computers um crashing and all
sorts of
issues the worm wasn't actually
malicious
so it didn't come in and try and destroy
anything
it was ju it was a sort of
i think somewhere between an academic
exercise and uh
and sort of highlighting the security
flaws
so it sort of moved around between
machines but the the problem with it was
that
uh it sort of infected the machine and
then it tried to infect other machines
and then it would infect another machine
but then that would come back and
reinfect this one
and it would get more and more copies of
this worm running on the
computer until eventually it just
keeled over or just ran out of resources
or whatever
so it used two or three different
ways of attacking so the first one was
uh there's a very
popular email program called send mail
that eric coleman wrote
from berkeley and that was used at a lot
of
computers at the time it was fiendishly
hard to configure but once you got it
configured
it was great and it dealt with all sorts
of complexities
but it had a sort of back door in it
that you could connect to it
and there's a whole lot of verbs you
could type in the smtp
dialog but one of them was debug which
wasn't a standard verb at all but
allowed you to sort of
switch into tracing and see what was
happening and things like that but one
of the things you could do there was run
a program
by surreptitious means so this is what
this worm did it it
it tried to connect this uh send mail
port and
immediately tried to switch into the
debug and if it
uh if it was compiled with the debug
switched on
then it could access things
and at this point um
people didn't really run binary
distributions of
computers you know like today you
download a program and you just run it
at that time you generally downloaded
the source code and you looked at it and
said
oh it's got all sorts of options which
of those do i want and you compiled it
up and used
whichever version you wanted so some
people got the debug
built in because they thought it would
be useful to
work out what was going wrong because
this were the early days and
things were going wrong all the time at
this point so there's quite a few of
those
another thing it used there was a
program called finger which
worked best on um multi-user programs
so this was a pro uh program you you
typed finger
which sounds a bit dodgy but um anyway
it gave you information about a user
it's not very useful today because
everybody's got their own computer
but on those days we had
like big computers in the basement with
maybe
40 or 50 terminals connected to it and
so you could see
find out information about other people
in the department and
say you know before walking around the
department to see
who was in you could just quickly see
are they in
or have they been active right it's a
good chance to go and
talk to them so once the internet
started
people thought oh this might be nice to
work between machines so they
they had a demon that just
would invoke this program and and send
you the results across the internet so
you could
then say okay is sean a computer file
active today and it would tell you yes
or no
the flaw with this program was it used a
very old
library call called get s which read a
line from the terminal
which was fine you just read in the line
but this one
read it into a buffer but it didn't say
how big the buffer was so you just
gave it a buffer and said read it into
that
and it had no way of knowing when it was
getting towards the end of the buffer
so typically people just declared a
buffer that was big enough and hoped
hoped it would work
and this were finger declared a buffer i
think 256
characters or something which was fairly
standard
but running under this finger d if you
sent
270 characters or something you'd come
off the end of the buffer and you'd
start writing onto the stack
and if you've placed the right
instructions there
this this time you have to be very
specific to the machine so you place vax
instruction machine
you could overwrite various bits of the
stack and then when it returned it would
jump into whatever you wanted
so he planted a little bomb there that
would jump into running a
command interpreter and then broke into
the machine once it was into the machine
it sort of copied itself
in it disguised itself it deleted the
original code
so that you couldn't actually see it
there and it disguised its name
so it would appear as something else in
the list of processes
and then it set about attacking other
machines so exploiting these two things
but once it was onto a machine it would
also look at um
there was a program called r shell which
uh has now been replaced by
s shell or ssh
and that that allowed you to jump
between machines if you had
your account set up so it would start
looking at accounts that it had got into
and say
oh could i use any of these it also had
a set of passwords
i think it had about 900 possible
passwords that
it would try it would also try the
user's name as its password and
user's name backwards as a password and
see if you could
get into other machines like that so it
had
two or three tactics for getting around
and
seemed to do extremely well so it was
written by
robert i think it's tappan morris he was
a student at cornell
at this point but he uh hacked into mit
and released it from there so that
presumably to sort of disguise himself
somewhat
awkwardly his father also called robert
morris was a
computer security expert worked at
uh bell telephone labs for some times
also worked at the nsa
so i expect that was going to be a few
awkward
conversations between father and son at
that point
because it quickly you know spread
throughout the internet and they
reckoned maybe
6 000 computers were infected
over this time it took a couple of days
to sort of remove it from each computer
because it uh it kept re-infecting and
they weren't
sure exactly what it was doing they
managed to eventually capture one of
these
um programs in the wild and disassemble
it and work out exactly what it was
doing and then they
they could work out how to stop it there
was a very quick
hack they found there was a program once
it got in
it tried to write to a temporary
directory
called the usertop sh if there was
was a file there it deleted it but it uh
it didn't actually check to see if that
was a file or a directory so if you
created a directory user top
sh that killed it so that was uh
one of the very early things that uh
found that you could stop it and then
you know eventually they worked out what
it was doing they
told everybody to recompile their send
mails without the debug switch
delete the finger d thing and
then gradually it sort of uh
managed to kill it off and uh stamped it
out but uh for a few days it was
it was quite chaos and there was just
you know messages on all the internet
chat things and all the uh
news groups saying hell we're under
attack what do we do and
people cut themselves off from the
internet which which was good
but then they couldn't find the advice
for how to stop it
so you know then they put themselves
back on to try and get an email out
what are we doing how do we get so um i
guess there's a lot of phone calls and
other things
this was a really big wake-up call for
the internet i mean as i said at this
point it'd be very
much you know we're all sort of
academics working together to try and
get this internet to work and we're
solving problems and so on and we're all
helping each other
and it was a very sort of free and open
culture
but this changed it in a big way very
suddenly
so suddenly security was much more of a
concern
that uh you know they started to look at
um
things they they have a set of
publications for internet standards
called rfc's request for comments
and they started mandating that you
explore all the
security implications of any new
protocol and
suddenly everybody got very
serious about security from that point
on and uh
you know that that was kind of the
transition from this
sort of playground of fun and uh
frolicks in the internet to
oh this is getting quite serious and uh
you know
we we can't live without the internet
now
and it's even you know it's obviously
much more relevant today but uh we've
come a long
way since those days did somebody find
out he'd done this or did he
raise his hand and say i'm really sorry
one of his friends
called the new york times and said um
there's this virus on the loose or with
this worm on the loose and
i it's i don't think he actually said
who it was but he did let slip
the initials of of the person and it
didn't take long for a report to work
out that uh
yeah rt rtm was this uh robert
type and morris and worked back
and worked out who it was i think he'd
gotten hidden by that point
uh he realized what uh what chaos he
called and
he was eventually convicted i've got 400
hours of community service and a fine of
10 050 significant at the time i'm sure
probably significant at the time
especially for a student who was a
you know in his first or second year of
university
fame secured he probably got some jobs
from then on in based on
being the guy who did that yeah i
remember not long after
i mean well a few months after when the
the
trauma had passed because it didn't
actually affect us in the uk we weren't
uh sufficiently well connected at that
point
but people were discussing would you
hire the guy who wrote this
because he's obviously quite skilled in
that you know he's managed to
break into a good fraction of the
computers and uh there's some discussion
on it you know some people were
still smarting from the blow and saying
absolutely not it was
horrible and others were saying well you
know he
has some good skills um directed in the
right way this this would probably be a
good thing to uh
to go for so uh yeah
i i think he has done reasonably well
since although i
haven't actually followed what he did i
don't think there were many copycats
of it at the time although it did
inspire things i i did actually have a
go at
writing something similar just to see
what it was but i was
fearfully careful not to let it run
right
and there was only two computers it
could infect anyway on our
small campus did it work to a degree it
was it was not
nearly as sophisticated as his it was
just a very simple script that cocked
itself
around and sat around but i made
absolutely sure
only one copy of it after a few
experiments i thought oh well
that that's that and uh i'll delete it
now before
moving on yes move on it's purely sort
of intellectual to say oh all right i've
never thought of how you could do that
could you write a program that could
copy its entirety somewhere else and
then run it and so on
of course you know we all know that's
quite possible now we've all
had experiences with worms infected
windows machines and things like that
this get s function is still available
today but
i look to the manual page and it says do
not ever use this function
and this is purely here for backwards
compatibility never ever use this
function so
you only have to work out whether it's
worth alerting the user
if you find the key so you know you
download the temporary exposure key you
perform the encryption
you generate the potential rpis and you
compare them with the ones you've seen
or if you want to more slightly
comprehensible message it's saying maybe
you haven't applied a function to
enough arguments